une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter dati compter avec moi
d'une plante si vous voulez nous
entendre parler encore plus après la
discussion d'homme nicole et moi on fait
un encore moins de filtres 20 à 30
minutes aux congés ce qui vient de se
passer est fait qu allez vous abonner
cette page piquionne y ait cette semaine
au podcast on a reçu au lit avec un mari
qui est bachelière en sexologie
conseillère en sexologie pour les
couples a personne pour les femmes pour
les hommes sur les réseaux sociaux
partout pour la suivre le paquet de six
semaines est présenté par vivre encore
une fois on vous a déjà parlé de leurs
trois lunch complet donc on a le bac
chili on a le mcs squash et on a le tome
taille et bien les vient de sortir trois
bases près culte des macaronis vous avez
du quinoa et du riz de chou-fleur que
vous n'avez qu'à faire chauffer et à
servir avec votre lunch
j'ai testé cette semaine on va voir ce
sauvé c'est votre bouille ph je vais
vous montrer comment c'est simple les
nouvelles bases de vie fait que j'aie
demi à 1 d'anticorps comme ceux de
tintin dans une casserole puis le g le
riz de chou fleur de revivre qui
arrivent comme ceux déjà congelés tu
t'es juste mais m
le chauffer de trois minutes se posait
après un retour avec un bol de riz
tchouf leur côté se pose aux riffs leur
taille
non mais c'est vraiment vraiment bon çà
mau prix max 5 minutes
ces bombes aux au rcv donc vivre
smoothie c'est un repas complet cv
gagnent c'est 100% naturel sans additif
faut manger d'havré bonne nourriture
nourrissante un code promo sans fil très
podcast 10 pour 1 10% de rabais sur
votre 1ere commande alors let's go on
commande des vives hier le podcast cette
semaine est également présentée par
memscap mindscape vous les connaissez ça
fait à cette fois qu'on en parle c'est
honnêtement les meilleurs produits pour
l'entretien sous la ceinture pis aussi
pour l'entretien en général vous voulez
votre meilleur ben même si je mens ce
qu'ils savaient faire pour vous je suis
tombé en avant et le parfum indiqué pied
des petits seront agrumes qui on me
complimente sur mon honneur depuis
j'utilise même skate
puis j'en suis quand même fier sinon
évidemment on ne lève blanc noir 3.0
l'instrument de trême par excellence
d'hommes de perdre son chargeur tunindex
est chagriné grande c'est peut être mon
chargeur plus jeu peut-être de vote tant
prêtons charger parce que c'est quand
même surpasser mes choses mes bijoux de
famille en ce moment commence à devenir
un petit peu fournis dans notre sort sur
des planches à ce niveau là je reçois
des le bureau des plaintes et
est très sollicité donc je vais déjà
vais devoir en prétendant charger ça te
dérange pop et acheter le pouvoir rpt
clean up de cette région
il faut en prendre soin de cette région
de nos produits on ne les mouches de
crise beaucoup les bords hype dans des
situations dures des situations en
arrière on active à la vie active ou
bien en fait le sait que sa lola gros
mais quand tu les 12 s'est détaché dans
le tarn en ce sens ton sec toujours un
bâlois est à portée de main et au bureau
tu veux te rafraîchir un petit peu et
bien du gain il rien pu que le sentiment
de ne pas être ferez pas être à son
meilleur mais ceux ci est un pack c'est
une douche ou un petit coup de barre
wipe et vous êtes reparti de plus belle
yes on vous encourage grandement à
acheter des trucs chez eux mêmes ce qui
est menaces et des produits avec
lesquels on est tombés en amour
puis on a un code promo pour vous autres
qui le sans filtre 20 pour 20% de rabais
et le shipping gratuit donc courez vous
procurer ce run run for your life fait
quoi on a reçu cette semaine au lit avec
un mari la sexualité mais on n'en parle
pas de castres puis de plus en plus je
trouve mais ton avec les avec joanie
pisan depuis on baigne un peu dans ce
depuis qu'on produit ici le podcast sexe
oral ont bien dans la sexuelle et même
dans l'esprit de l'ouverture sexuels
mettant un excellent centre facilement
les conversations comme seul mais oui
vraiment ça ça des tabous is plein de
choses à les voir dans l'addiction est
allé dans plein de directions de choses
des relations de couple de couple ouvert
depuis somme on a parlé de ça on parlait
de débats lancement de libido tous eu
des choses qui ont nui plusieurs avis
vraie vie je pense qu'ils aient peu
importe ce que peut-être vous un peu la
conclusion de podcasts le pids allez
voir par vous même et c'est normal ouais
c'est normal d'avoir des questionnements
c'est normal de vivre à faire on pense
deux fois qu'on est tout seul mais
vraiment peau en ville tout les mêmes
enfants
qui à maryse ranspach personnes de
l'équipe allait être à connaît son sujet
connaissant matière donc donc allons-y
plongeon dans cette discussion plongeon
dans ces discussions mais juste avant
laissez-nous atom à abonner vous à nos
shine les seynois racing si vous écoutez
en ce moment en barrados avoue prendre
cinq secondes à faire un monde de
différence pour nous donc sans plus
attendre
bompas de caste
[Musique]
c'est parti est merci d'être là on va
continuer parce qu'on a une bonne
conversation depuis qu'on est assis à
linxe à tourner dans le fond on parle
des ventes en ligne des objets sexuels
puis de commençal explosé avec la
pandémie qui le point qu'on a amené
jusque là c'était me semble que c'est ça
fait acheter des jouets sexuels en ligne
c'est tellement plus confortable calais
en magasin fait que ça peut sûrement
expliquer pourquoi la vente en ligne
autant explosé lorsqu'ils se déplacent
dans un sex-shop c'est pas la chose à
moitié à moins que tu es vraiment soit
aucunement gêné que tu as besoin de
faire conseiller
la magie magie n'a acheté des affaires
puis je serai plus à l'aise tous à la
personne personnellement karma mais je
pense qu'en ligne est tellement de choix
que c'est sam hamad et bien mélanger
il ya erreur qui a un chat dans le
supermarché sur le site internet mais
l'on peut parler en live avec des
conseillers et conseillères qui font la
même job qu'en boutique dans vos bacs
tout les avantages d'une boutique mais
sur le web
pas de quoi rembourser candidat c'est
parce que moi je moi je tallinn fois
acheter quelque chose dans un sex-shop
il pige jetaient pas confortable c'est
pas parce que avec avec la sexualité
mais juste parce que fallait quand même
que j'explique mes besoins à quelqu'un
que je connaissais pas puisque ça me
rendait pas foule bien effectivement je
peux faire ça en ligne clavardait
quelqu'un dirait sur ce see sûrement
mieux à clamart t même mois avant de
commencer à en parler sur instagram des
jouets sexuels
je pourrais acheter peut être une adepte
loi des boutiques érotiques le jeudi
même si c'est un peu le monde domine et
jetez pas quelqu'un qui allait
régulièrement pis je me rappelle la
première fois que je suis rentré dans
une boutique érotique cgu legros speech
de haoues il en fait à une de mes amies
puis j'aimerais ça lui acheter quelque
chose c'est qu'ils viennent bleus de
quoi
je sais pas pour moi la forêt la ville
un jour j'ai fait
j'étais certaine et lui répéter que ce
n'est pas au mois de mai dans le top
j'ai déballé sur sa page est identique
jeudi c'est la sexualité c'est déjà un
sujet qui est tabou se rend dans une
place où c'est comme c'est juste de se
la sexualité il ya des images graphiques
et des terrains et des jouets des
impacts jamais vitalic ce n'est pas que
ça sert fait coincer ces systèmes est
intimidant mais téléconseillère en
boutiques sont habituelles sont faux nom
quand même la réaction t'appartient pas
ca t1 imerys appelle berne atypique ait
fait un sketch sur le moment où est ce
que tu vas où ce que tu allais d'acheter
une poupée gonflable
si je le fais comme si tu savais qu'elle
cherchait plus d'être en coupe d'europe
qui t'arrive ou comptoir et c'est aux
jeux seraient pas tous il a un labo la
tribu racheter sa joie l'essayer depuis
que tu es on a travaillé les clés fille
soit six heures à la sortie j'ai
tellement appris de fermeture
johanniques à connaître le manceau ce
mardi c'est incroyable j'ai tellement
appris genre des produits chlorés pack
existait des manières de vie sexuelle
dit que j'allais passer des choses la
tendance et pratique
oui oui comment des choix et quand même
un coup de main c'est ainsi comment dire
ça commence par chanter c'est ainsi je
fais un gros ce qu'ils appellent la main
ok d'un jargon qui est taclé ont essayé
d affaires bouteflika
mais pour toi non plus mais jamais pour
toi j'ai bien et n'ont jamais non jamais
pour moi
ascom déçu c'est comme christiane ça
comme ça comme planter au moins c'est
que je suis pas fermé le dire je peux te
faire mal mais chaque chose en son temps
mais il craint m crawl genre j'imagine
qu'on imagine par exemple utile mais si
ces incidents qu'un tyran dit tantôt
c'est bien là qu'il en soit comme
fantasme canal anal analyse alors c'est
comme on dirait que c'est comme est des
fois c'est un but à atteindre pour
certaines personnes puis quand ces rôles
tantôt on dirait que certains grossistes
et comme oui mais temouchent proust et
georges pauget or une zone sinistrée
palois d'approcher leur nuit ça vaut
mais moi ce jeu pas encore rendus là
peut-être que ce que je vous le dirai
jamais non
mais est ce que toi avec tout ça fait
combien de temps que tu étais en ligne
en fait le ticket dessus que tu
conseilles les gens que tu aides les
gens dans leur sexualité en ligne et
j'ai commencé mon compte instagram
ça va faire deux ans au début j'avais
aucune idée de ce que je fais il a fini
son bac 1 en avril dernier que l'acteur
phare runner kg gratuit et puis ces
sujets j'ai commencé ma page enfants
dans ma deuxième année d'université
j'avais déjà l'idée de la commencé quand
j'ai commencé mon bac
c'était comme un but pour voir mais je
trouvais que j'avais pas assez
d'informations puisque j'ai passé de
connaissances pour commencer à me cmmtq
en tant qu'experte sur les réseaux
sociaux
enfin que j'entends les étrangers à ma
deuxième année de bac même je serai un
an et demi dans mon bac j'ai commencé ma
page avec ça fait 2-1 puis
au début j'ai pour règle je savais même
pas comment ça fonctionne et instagram
j'avais aucune idée ma page personnelle
je m'étais jamais rien dessus puis c'est
des amis qui m'ont aidé et tu devrais
faire un espèce de partir une sur ta
page pour que ça soit beau
esthétiquement quand on rentre sur ta
page
et puis je me rappelle mes premières
chroniques là ça peut prendre des heures
et des heures tournée me stories de 15
secondes le parquet tu es tellement
critique de toi-même piteux pas de faire
juger fac il est ce que quand tu es dans
ton bac diaz je veux partir c'est ce que
c'est parce que tu avais remarqué un
manque qui à cet endroit là où est-ce
que c'était quoi la motivation derrière
l'idée de devenir un peu cette personne
publique le dessus j'ai toujours eu un
intérêt à dans la communication j'ai
fait promedia je sais pas si vous
connaissez
lg avait promise il ya quelques années
mais en vrai que j'avais rien à redire
fac je voyais pas le point le but
continuer dans cette veine là et je vais
pas parler juste de tout et de rien du
bien commun spécialisée dans quelque
chose fac puis quand charvet en sexo si
j'avais un peu mise sur rail l'autre
côté si on veut qu'ils je suis allé dans
les écoles secondaires faire des cours
en tant que bénévole avec un programme
qui s'appelle s'experts qu'il est
question que je recevais les gens
revenaient peu de tout et questionnement
ça va vraiment fait prendre conscience
qu'il ya un besoin et un besoin
d'éducation sexuelle
je me suis dit bon je veux juste arrivé
mais ni passion si on veut pis je veux
je veux je veux commencer par un sacre
c'est quoi pour revenir ce que tu as dit
c'est quoi des questions c'est quoi le
manque que tu voyais qu'ils aient acquis
il vraiment quelque chose qui vraiment
un besoin à combler c'est quoi des
questions qu'ils posent les jeunes les
gens vont savoir si son arme aux normes
aux normes otan dans autant mettons dans
l'or
dans l'image de leur pratique dans leurs
fantasmes que dans leurs envies anatomy
dans tout le seuil était pensé tonton
anatomy les gens je me fait écrire peu
importe l'âge de six mois j'étais j'ai
pris conscience de soi dans les écoles
secondaires mais on a commenté je vais
chez le dentiste puis je dis à mon
hygiène dentaire que je suis en
sexologie pc comme mobile iphone et ben
khoudja club du fai et les jantes dès
que les gens savent qui était dans ce
domaine leur montrer qu'il ya comme une
confiance qui s'installe instantanément
puis tu as des connaissances que pas de
beaucoup de monde on fait que les gens
sont vraiment toujours enclins à poser
des questions chez perfect pour moi
c'est comme si un entraîneur josé puis
je dire le succès aussi de mappage
instagram est pas attribuable
nécessairement à moi mais plus au
contenu de ma part j'ai l'impression
donc il ya vraiment un besoin puis
piquent les questions tu reçois
j'imagine que 99% du temps les gens sont
normaux oui ce qui est énorme
normal c'est sur le point bas à moi qui
ai qatari avec quelques jours de
comblement je suppose oui c'est un peu
comme si je la vois non mais c'est
quelque chose méthodes illégales même
temps ah ouais mais ça doit être pas mal
tout le temps les mêmes affable un
questionnement que tout le monde à
gauche finalement way we say it à matt
et moi je me positionne après comme je
tendrai la ministre sur ma page
instagram géosynthétiques en études
féministes avant de faire mon baquet en
sexo fac c'est évidemment je parle la
sexualité surtout des personnes qui ont
un vagin des femmes qui s'est beaucoup
des femmes qui viennent de poser des
questions sur mon vagin ce qui est
normal et j'ai pas d'orgasme
est ce que c'est normal j'ai pas
d'orgasme avec un ou une partenaire est
ce que c'est normal
knox est constamment des questions comme
ceux que j'ai l'impression que c'est des
questions qui il ya comme un besoin de
déconstruire certains mythes qui ont
amassé des mythes qui proviennent du
patriarche copte si j'essaie de ne pas
trop salée féministe dans mon discours
parce que je sais que ça peut déranger
des gens mais il ya vraiment quelque
chose
le patriarcat vraiment un thé notre
façon de vivre notre sexuelle massant
pour ça mais qui peut aussi expliquer
plus comment comment ça c'est fait
et s'en explique c'est quoi le mail et
les l'aimé conception puis d'où ça vient
puis comment que le patriarcat joue un
rôle là dedans mais ton baisse et on a
souvent misé sur le plaisir des hommes
qui en fait la femme avait une fonction
reproductive si on restait à la maison
on avait des enfants et erreur donc dit
si tu étais pas fertile savait pas grand
chose
je vais parler travail et on a un peu
droit de vote et c'est gratuit on a
vraiment fait du chemin
moi qui ai d'enfants on avait vraiment
une fonction de reproduction qui on a
vraiment misé sur la pénétration à cause
de ce qu'il ya comme toute l'histoire du
clitoris ce sujet ferait podcast avec s
mais l'élection est tranquille dans les
banlieues
ouais ouais bonne idée parce que les
gens pourraient le clitoris gagnant à
être connue c'est comme ça que les
femmes ont des orgasmes et personnes qui
ont 1 verge et c'est avec la stimulation
du clitoris que ce soit le 6 nations
directe ou indirecte dans le gaz
c'est la crise c'est grâce à lui qu'on a
un orgasme ce qui explique notre cas ce
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est que
tu es un organe qui a été vraiment pas
étudié vraiment méconnu vraiment un côté
à cause que justement ça se cultive
c'est le plaisir quand moi c'est juste
le baiser fac et oui c'est ça l'orgasme
chez les personnes qui ont un parent n'a
pas de fonction procréative chez les
hommes les personnes qui ont un pénis
l'éjaculation vient avec leurs gardes ça
peut être dit ceci message ferme ta fac
chez les femmes on s'est rendu compte
qu'elle possède avoir un orgasme pour
être dans les facs et les ailes et on a
enlevé l'importance de l'orgasme chez la
femme qui on a juste utilisé la femme
comme quelqu'un qui est vraiment quelque
chose d'illogique là dedans parce que
c'est si un petit haut risque vraiment
qu'on serait tout être humain parce que
l'idée même ça n'a pas besoin pour
qu'ils y aillent
une conception d'un enfant l'idée
d'avoir un orgasme pile des caïds du
plaisir donne envie d'avoir des
relations sexuelles qui doit donner des
enfants quand drôle parce que justement
mais justement maintenant dans la
conception patriarcal pour comprendre
reprendre la terminologie pour dans la
conception patrie acte patriarcal de la
sexualité
l'orgasme la femme on sent quand les
piles ni le plaisir de la femme aussi
team et on mangeait en exemple le
la job de maman conter une histoire où
est ce que lui je pense qu'il y avait
comme onze frères et soeur puis sa mère
jamais vu son père nu fait dans le fond
sont pas arrivés il ya pencher sur lui
il faisait ce qu'ils avaient à faire
puis à lui aux enfants rien il semble
sans avoir d'orgasmes dans la
reproduction on prend le maquis qui
prenait son bain il devait à devait se
toucher ou je sais pas quoi
possiblement qu'elle avait des orgasmes
dans d'autres contextes mais y'avait pas
de plaisir dans l'acte de reproduction
fait que je pas sûr que que je peux sur
que 500 kits au risque pas de pas de vie
le petit doigt ceux du moyen mais tu as
raison parce que moi souvent je veux
dire que la seule fonction du clitoris
est procuré du plaisir plomb commence à
me dire dénoncé le guitariste en sorte
que tu as envie tous des envies et
cetera oui c'est vrai il ya une certaine
fonction aux qataris c'est qu'ils vont
la pulsion d'avoir des rapports sexuels
si je devais avoir des enfants c'est un
choix fait pour avoir des enfants
oktay des rapports sexuels mais on est
des êtres de pulsions pis c'est pas ce
qu'on sait pour la survie de la race
humaine envers tout ce qu'on a toutes
ses pulsions le les animaux on s'est
même pulsion leur sens même incapable de
mettre des mots là dessus ou des tabous
si on veut pas qu'elle mettait toute
l'histoire des scripts sexuelles avec la
pénétration jeudi il ya juste une
personne avec un vagin sur cinq qui va
avoir un orgasme grâce à la pénétration
c'est prouvé que si on offrait plus de
sexe oral aux femmes mais elles auraient
plus d'orgasmes et mais elles sont
beaucoup plus enclines à en offrir 40 de
ses lignes d'une statistique pour ce oui
je suis curieux c'est quoi mettons le
pourcentage des ménages ou est ce qu'il
ya un débalancement dans le sexe oral
aux formes et ont su statistique existe
un jeu précis de trouver des études
latines
on va parler le corps de jouissance et
il ya une étude qui était conduit par
pensée de john kaiser sexuelle behavior
quelque chose genre qui ont conclu que
dans la rétine leurs échantillons ayant
vraiment fait une étude sur des hommes
si genre hétérosexuels gays des
lesbiennes des bisexuels
des femmes hétéros et c'est qu'ils l'ont
vraiment demandé toi est-ce que tu
atteins toujours l'orgasme lors des
rapports sexuels
les hommes 6 hétéros ont dit oui à 95%
méchant bon pourcentage est beaucoup ça
effectivement
ouais c'est comme c'est satisfaisant ça
y est les femmes hétéros ce genre on est
à 60 5% il ya un écart de 30 % de
jouissance le style beaucoup il est
lesbienne
elles sont à 86 pour ça tu y as un décor
de 20% entre les femmes hétéros que les
femmes lesbiennes fac c'est supposer que
les scripts sexuelles sont vraiment peu
adaptés y en a moins de pénétration
entre avec deux femmes la fac et puis à
plus de stimulation du clitoris est donc
beaucoup plus d'orgasmes mégots jetés
peuples égaux la seconde est gros mais
si ça se passe que la relation sexuelle
dit classique l'âme et on va commencer
qu'à pénétration va finir quel goût
vient fille dati s'est réglé puisque la
fille entre les deux quand les deux
événements et pau venus du guizhou
ouais il ya une autre étude là dessus
c'est 56 % des hommes puis l'on parle
des relations hétérosexuelles ce genre
5% des hommes 56 % des hommes hétéros
pense que c'est pas nécessaire pour les
femmes d'avoir un orgasme lors des
relations sexuelles qu'ils ont quand
même ce plaisir alors que 56 pour savons
également mentionné ne pas avoir de
plaisir lors des rapports sexuels si on
peu de regards sont ok puis mettons et
qui apprennent des communications et
sinon oui oui oui oui vulgarité comme
hugo problèmes notamment parce que ouais
et oui mais maintenant ce que moi je me
suis dit
puis corrige moi si je me trompe
peut-être que c'est juste des filles qui
monte sur pour me faire plaisir et mais
mais
mais en mois d'ici au 18 mai puis même
moi moi aussi quand quand même temps je
prends mon exemple perso sur l'honneur
sur ce qu'on m'a dit moi quand des fois
j'ai pas d'orgasme samarie j'ai quand
même du plaisir dans l'acte sexuel puis
des voix c'est arrivé que j'ai eu des
relations sexuelles ou est-ce que la
fille aux poètes d'orgasme et que je
disais c'est correct genre on peut
continuer comme nom moi c'était c'était
le fun quand même qu'ils se 6 si tu
verrais le style von karman s'était
satisfait non mais s'impose 7-6 mêmes
escrocs cia voulait pas continuer mais
on est beaucoup dans l'axé des deux
performant en pis il ya d'autres études
ans et âgé parmi mes chiffres mais il ya
des beaucoup de femmes
il s'est vraiment à des baux pourcentage
le et était pourquoi sketches comiques
petits besoins ton partenaire y en a
beaucoup qui ont peur de faire la pierre
alors maintenant le coût que savent pas
commun parce qu'elles savent même pas ce
qu'ils aiment facultés on va se
contenter des fois de plus non pas sur
le fond
oui parce qu'elle après ça il prend du
temps pour atteindre l'orgasme
c'est normal que ça prenne du temps pour
atteindre l'orgasme serviront quatre
minutes en moyenne que ça prend seul le
sait pas parce qu'ils ont beau que vous
êtes en eau en pensant que vous n'êtes
pas normal à qui je tiens à mentionner
way puis avec un partenaire ou une
partenaire encore plus longue a ajouté
le faut que tu fous qu'ils soient dans
ton assiette le faut que tu arrêtes de
penser que c est long parce qu'elle est
l'autre personne votre hui selon le home
on dit plus
écoute ça peut devenir le pion rendant
l'accès des deux performances même pour
atteindre l'orgasme est ce que les
femmes vivent plus dans cette
performance que les hommes où les hommes
vivent aussi j'ai c'est une bonne
question je convaincu qui en a dans les
deux sens et si j'ai des clientes qui
vont dire que lorsqu'elle mentionne dans
leurs partenaires qu'ils atteignent pas
l'orgasme qu'il ya les partenaires sont
comme il y en a qui sont forts chez de
ce type où il y en a qui ont caché à
leurs partenaires qu'elle n'atteignait
pas l'orgasme cas précis comme sont
forts chez ce moment ci c'est insultant
et puis mais non il demande lui à la
place qu est ce que je peux faire pour
te voyons que je mentais l'orgasme et le
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour t'aider
est ce que tu es capable sur qu'est ce
que tu fais quand tu es seul comment que
je peux participer à tous et mais cette
réaction l'alcool
est ce parce que c'est une atteinte à
leur ego la puissante insuffisant
puissante et incapable de pitié de moi
je me suis déjà fait dire le teaser pour
la question et tout je te fais ce qui me
tombe y ont laissé seager grippe c'est
comme si c'est jamal fans attendent
parce que tu es tu as l'impression que
tu veux de les faire tu veux bien faire
les choses
l'impression que tout le monde est
content typique et puis finalement au
nom s'était passé de 6 pi mais c'est un
phénomène qui est spécial c'est
qu'est-ce qui est pas ce que c'est qu'un
courant je pense le fait de faire
semblant l'été ou la caisse qui que ce
qui amène ce bain c'est la peur de
comics était besoin y en a beaucoup qui
savent même pas et je défends ma
consultation qui vient l'europe qui nous
lisent avant de découvrir tapage je
savais même pas qu'il fallait que je
stimule monkey terroristes pour antenne
orgasme donc j'ai masturber avec
pénétration parce que ben c'est ce qu'il
faut faire sans l'air bag factice et ce
jeu passé à peu près 80 % des femmes ont
des jeux simuler l'orgasme
mais ma chaîne sport iphone se faire
dire qu'on a signé leur regain de forme
machinerie non je comprendre je
comprends que je faisais juste de mon
point de vue mais je comprends qu'elles
cesseront smartphone avoir à faire ce
qui peut se sentir à l'aise de desbiens
exprimé des besoins des commandites sens
c'est sûr que c'est ce qui est dit est
ce que mettons là la communication
promettons est ce que c'est que relaie
la plus tu connais ton corps puis plus
tu es capable d'atteindre l'orgasme par
toi même plus tu vas être confiant
confiante de communiquer avec ton ou ta
partenaire ce que tu veux de fanfares
dont 100% fait que sa part de la
connaissance de son corps en 1er juin
comment veux tu donner chemin à
quelqu'un c'était yeux bandés
ouais ok valgorge vadrot peut rentrer
dans le bain et facilement vaincu c'est
vraiment c'est tout passe selon moi la
masturbation c'est comme un peu pour la
réponse à tout mais disons que c'est
trés ça sert à ces prêts utiles dont le
comme ce témoin suivant on va revenir à
sauter
j'attends pas l'orgasme avec mon ma
partenaire parfait est ce que tu te
masturbes non est ce que tu sais ce que
tu aimes non mais là c'est de sa faute
il devrait savoir comment faire non je
suis devrait savoir comment ton corps
fonctionne quitte je dire on vient pas
avec des livres d'instruction fait qu'il
faut se trouver comment on fonctionne
après c'est faut être capable de
communiquer tpiy après ça devient
difficile parce que l'on n'a pas de
froisser notre partenaire on n'a pas
d'être compliqué on
mais je pense que plus on va normaliser
les discussions autour de tout ça plus
on va ouvrir la porte justement aux
discussions parlant les rapports sexuels
qui moi ce que je conseille aussi aux
gestes des phases du pire au toc
après des rapports sexuels dont tu
parles de dancing et oui ok cool qui
parfait en gare sera lancée - non mais
ça c'est vraiment un petit stand six
mois puis puis s'écroule ça je te mentir
ça fait un petit à petit chaque point
qu'on est sûr qu'on est quand même
longueur d'onde piqué quant à connaître
présents tous les deux qui est qu'on
aime les mêmes fabriqué c'est un très
bon bah oui c'est ce jeudi et on se met
à nu on se met à nu avec l'autre
personne qui ne veut pas qu'on en parle
et moi ce jeu dangereux comprendre ce
problème parce que moi je suis à l'aise
dans ma sexualité mais non on n'en parle
pas c'est quoi ton tu en parles pas une
personne pour la plupart des gens qui
sont morgane et avec qui tu as des
rapports sexuels dans ta vie tu en
parles pour moi c'est quand même nom et
ouvre la discussion lui il faut en
parler je dire je commence une business
avec des partenaires d'affaires tandis
meeting qui est ce ça va marcher comme
ce soit ça va fonctionner le manque soit
ça fonctionne peu ok c'est quoi la
solution s'est elle pas refaire le passé
ce qui sait ce qui m'attend quand
j'entends joannie que je trouve beau et
inspire ans à quel point elle tia nos
aînés pas de tabous mettant le tipi
clairement son charme non plus factice
il n'y a pas de limite à la discussion
perlé ya pas d y ait pas de zone taboue
sait comment pu discuter tout on peut
tout essayer
on peut tout et tout et tout est sur la
table
et puis je trouve ça cool tichot se
couche sur ce boulevard ceux des gens
qui sont prêts à essayer toutes ces
affaires le pied tout à aller plus loin
puis à tout le temps remettre en
question à mettre en doute parce que tu
sais je pense que les dangers s'écarter
des longues relations ammann est tombé
dans une grotte de groupe
s'il devient quelque chose qu'on peut
plus changer parce que ça fait tellement
longtemps que d'une certaine façon plus
terre
questionné c'est comme s'il est perçu
comme une attaque ou de souhaiter se
sont pas quittés de jeu que 12 du monde
qui t'ont amené ce problème le mai mais
moins c'est de toujours garder
discussions ouvertes dans le fond tu
mets le petit parti même si c'est pour
les longues relations mais même mettons
je repense aux fois parce que j'ai des
relations avec le monde que je
fréquentais qui étaient soit soit des
one night soit de plusieurs relations
dans une période de temps x ou est-ce
que si à vue communication au début
avant que ça commence ou pis même
pendant la soirée était dix fois mieux
qu'est ce que ça a été parce que quand
il n'y a pas de communication si c'est
juste moyen pour tout le monde petits et
même même autant pour les longues
relations de mettre des barèmes autant
au début de faire quand même moi ce
gemstone même puis allons-y comme thirty
irait couture c'est guide parfait fait
que c'est sûr que non c'est c'est
intéressant puis j'ai l'impression que
corrigez moi si je me trompe que de plus
en plus dans les dernières années le ya
vraiment un espèce de mouvance vers la
découverte de sa propre sexualité tu as
tu remarqué sur deux dans l'air du temps
oui 100 % puis andrée qui est un boom
depuis la pandémie a dit séverine
clients car qui me disait il ya un an
j'aurais jamais fait se mélangeraient
j'ai le temps les gens vont investir du
temps dans leur santé mentale dans leur
santé physique dans leurs relations
amicales amoureuses et intérêts mais
jamais dans leur sexualité
puis on pense que les orgasmes tombe du
ciel qui est le désir sexuel top 10 6%
avant tout le monde en eux mais c'est
pas comme ça il faut travailler sur
notre santé sexuelle faut mettre du
temps si je pense que la pandémie a
apporté ce dans nos vies de ralentir le
temps fort c'est évident le sol humanité
six mois comme ça fait 2 tours de
netflix était fait c'est aussi juste un
petit monde
joannie and hands a donné un
masturbateur puis pis moi m'a sauvé à
tort je ne sais pas quelque chose que
j'avais entendu fleshlight restée
coincée dans ma tête mais là on se
donnait masturbateur puis à mafate deux
semaines plus tard on fait un zoom avec
une coupe de mes amis puis toutes les
deux sont encore petits puis le savent
bien sûr le soudeur massoma top le yacht
deux des blondes des gars qui écouter la
conversation qui arrive alors à masseube
à tort dans le jacc foraines sont aussi
on l'appuie jamais très à cause qu'il
l'avait entendu le podcast right away à
coup ce qu'il avait entendu le patient
sur six
le cje oreilles on découvre
masturbatoire puis d'envoi introduire
sopi en plus avec une des filles qui
disait jaurès qui commentait aux autres
blonde qui n'avait pas acheté genres et
les filles ça va changer votre ville est
comme si c'était des coups qui n'était
pas du tout dans qui était du tout dans
dans l'imaginaire des janves le même pas
un an là dessus je pense qu'il faut voir
les jouets sexuels comme des outils pour
agrémenter en a qui s'entend compétition
comptait jouer c'est que j'avais j'ai un
goût qui m'écrit très serré montre qu'on
me dit ah c'est ça vous allez nous
remplacer par ceux aucune chance que je
remplace un homme mais ce qui est moche
hétérosexuels un homme par un jouet
sexuel je vous ai vu un jeu sexuel
membres a cependant coupait pas de
chaleur kiev s'est vraiment mal
comprendre les femmes de penser que je
suis objectif de remplacer jean
l'affection pilati tout ce qui est
autour des centrales mais le performant
la motiver mes plus grands la
performante et si je disais partager une
historie arkeia rohner là on a reçu des
commandes de performant ouais exactement
t on écoule tout notre stock
c'est de plus en plus vite que la danse
est en quatre arrières en 1h30 le 6 3 la
folie autour de ces jouets ils étaient
fiasse
il porte bien son nom mais juste avant
j'ai demandé aux femmes aux
propriétaires de performances seraient
moins 50 de mener un mot pour le décrire
quelqu'un qui fut jamais besoin d'hommes
dans ma vie
les stickers et plus qu'un groupe 2 mais
je peux aussi liste devrait aller le nom
c'était mais en même temps si si ça
parle un peu de tout
la problématique autour de cet écart
s'est rendu parce que ton jouet le
sétois qui guident aussi un fac mais
c'est de prendre conscience si que
l'hôte et toi tu la plastique de façon
que m le fait de signer de façon mais
fait ça avec ton homme moins séduit
qu'enfin fact et oui c'est autant la job
d'être réceptif réceptive aux commandes
mais c'est aussi de trouver ses propres
commandes d'enquêteurs sur des questions
beaucoup sur internet sur ta page
intérim du sommet qui fait aussi la
consultation avec la vie des gens
est-ce que c'est surtout les coupes
surtout défendre tous les hommes c'est
commencer quoi la proportion est en
échec c'est surtout des femmes des
piscines je sais par expérience et je me
suis vraiment positionné en tant que
féministe c'est ma page a érodé si je
suis vraiment dans les longueurs paquet
oui c'est surtout des femmes qui est
pour rien je triple g tri de masques et
je sais que j'ai un impact dans la vie
sexuelle des personnes qui passent dans
ma vie ou qui pensent même sur ma page
je me poserai avoir une consultation
pour comprendre des choses donc je pense
que c'est vraiment la magie des réseaux
sociaux d étudier quelles étaient tes
amis leurs blondes ont acheté des jouets
sexuels métis parce que c'est en
normalisant la discussion qu'on se rend
compte de toutes ces choses le suggère
donc constamment est en compétition avec
le masturbateur si on sent plus comme un
banc même équipe que 20 c'est quelque
chose de l'fun ces picards choses et
j'ai fait des démos et à domicile
je faisais mon bac j'en écoute quasi
l'avoir la pandémie le puits et je
faisais acheté à mes clientes
si je leur disais était fin de soirée le
tout libanais sur pie xi et commence à
le masturber avec ceux ci c'est
surprenant pipe comme impies tilt en
partenaire si tu penses à lui ou à et
quand tu y fais des petites choses comme
ça donc si je pense que c'est juste de
donner créative créatives comme semence
elle est tantôt on est très linéaire
dans notre façon de vivre la sexualité
on commence avec l'érection les
préliminaires de revenir après ça on
mise sur la pénétration c'est comme les
les scellés plus du spectacle qui après
cei à l'orgasme
mais comme on peut le faire la sexualité
un but et j'ai l'impression que c'est un
peu le même principe qui mettons tous
les films de super héros le quai commun
une trajectoire d'un moteur narratif qui
est toujours le même depuis la haye
tandis qu'on hydril et par la porn qui
est une pointe fait pour le plaisir de
l'homme mais là on reproduit ça dans
notre sexualité plus le problème de
machine
ouais mais je pensais tout les scripts
qui nous sont imposées par les médias
que ce soit ça y est tu regardes et même
des défis mais ses erreurs le petit veau
des gens à pratiquer des préliminaires
ça va être la pénétration et puis on
nous met tout l'aspect après deux autres
le il ya un orgasme bail ce cauchemar à
côté de l'autre à prescrire le poids de
fluides s'est évaporé paquet mais c'est
pas mal ça se passe après un rapport
sexuel on sait tout contours toilettes
comme ça qu'est le regard cette pilule à
sa coupe à prochaines semaines c'est
tout le temps si ça arrive je l'appelle
j'écoutais dans wrath of khan qui en
scène lorsqu'ils finissent de chansons
qu'il a fait à prendre et kleenex place
et suit ses pilotes
je me rappelle c'est de quoi que tout le
monde fait mais qu'en le voyant arriver
je fais toujours un mais c'est clair
c'est que l'appui mettons qu'on mettons
que
on veut essayer de construire 6 creed la
con qu'on a construit au-dessus dès
qu'elles sont maintenant les lapointe
féministe ça existe fait que comment est
ce que on déconstruit seul donc on veut
activement les déconstruire mettewie
lapointe fini film the damage mange mil
à la pole féministe oui ça peut être
utile métis c'est sûr que les scripts
qui se ressemble quand même un peu je
pense que la notion de consentement est
beaucoup plus présente la diversité
aussi des corps la diversité culturelle
et ses terrasses est beaucoup plus
présente
mais pour vrai c'est vraiment en en
parlant juste par un peu de casse comme
c'est les gens qui vont écouter que mon
frère comme c'est vrai antilles enfin on
fait bien qu'ils soient de la
pénétration puis j'aimerais cependant
avoir plus de sexe oral avec après ça
c'est d'aller parler avec ton ta
partenaire d'essayer de voir c'est quoi
son ouverture par rapport à ceux il ya
des applications qui existe vraiment été
discussions avec ton ta partenaire c'est
pour comme pour pas que ça soit toi qui
a même réussi j'ai d'abord comme un
outil qui trouve une porte
les jouets et les jeux érotiques qui en
ont parlé dans sexe oral et je pensais
dans l'ancien à lantin et jeux de
société et si je pense à aphrodisiaques
par exemple qui est un jeu un peu plus
je joigne à dick et crémeux cochons et
qui émeut les traditions qui s'adonnent
les vêtements paquet qui dansait dans
ses geôles otis et il ya des défis mais
comme c'est des affaires qui fait
peut-être pas dans ton lentilles script
sexuelle des traditionnelles qui étaient
à petit par après virginie soir à sept
heures merci à tous les jeudis le tri de
virgile hockey
des fois j'ai des références quand même
en consultation avec mes clients je me
dis mon dieu je vieillis
game car l'ipad strict 31 jean gauthier
ok mais c'est sophie pipi c'est comme
ces jeux là te propose des choses ses
pieds le sélect ont piloté qu'embarque
c'est comme c'est quand qu'on a fait
c'est en tout le wawa je pense j'ai
vraiment aimé ce fait que ton partenaire
ta partenaire prend sans notes
mentalement pour j'ai d'abord un white
bull qui s'est tu leur fais au prochain
au prochain au prochain tour puis pas
que c'est juste c'est de s'ouvrir
d'aller chercher les outils que tout
autour de toi pour ouvrir la discussion
il ya aussi dans cette discussion là
j'ai l'impression une place importante
d'ego qui nécessite de sens à lille
parce que steam et on l'a amenée pour la
pour l'avoir déjà amené dans une
conversation dans une relation que
j'avais amené le trépas 3 mettons le qui
est une des que topeak tu veux explorer
l'idée avec la personne c'est difficile
d'amener ce puits que ce soit bien reçu
parce que mais du moins de mon
expérience parce que souvent ça sonne
comme j'aimerais ça con qu'on aille voir
ailleurs
j'aimerais aller voir ailleurs mais
métier le faire en respectant notre
notre code ensemble
j'ai l'impression que quand et
inversement quand des affaires comme ça
aussi ne sont présentés souvent c'est
l'ego qui embarque qui a de la
difficulté à accepter ce genre de
conversation le web
lego est interne aux croyances rex qui
tu peux faire c'est que quand tu
apportes le sujet attentats partenaire
ben tu peux commencer évidemment dans la
question ses croyances sur le sujet que
ce soit et même des gens qui sont pas
d'accord qui alors pas traverser
masturbe danse qui sont en relation
c'est quoi tes croyances là pourquoi
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment de les
déconstruire toute la pensée derrière ce
pays après c'est d'aligner vos
perceptions et puis de dire 26 mois si
je vois que telle croyance par rapport
aux tripes à 3 mais pour moi et c'est
pas la même chose
moi je le vois plus comme telle et telle
affaire fac-ci de s'expliquer dans nos
perceptions dans nos croyances fit
parler parler du sujet
très pas trop avant de proposer
nécessairement l'intervention devient
une réaction j'ai l'impression que tu me
connais je me trompe que tu y mets ton
certaines pratiques certains isaac
métrosexuels vont été je pense que
l'untm et anguilles mais plus avancés
que d'autres le ti qui hâtent deuxième
puis leur médecin puis j'ai l'impression
que pour amener quelque chose
un sujet que des cas comme ceux-là faut
que la communication soit vraiment bonne
il faut que tu ailles aussi expérimenté
bande et affable suspects ouverts en a
parlé
si tu parle jamais de sexualité avec un
partenaire qui est justement très
heureux si je dis pas au revoir c'est
votre sexualité vous en parlez foule
s'est située dans une vieille affaire à
manier ça peut peut-être sur les
nouvelles affaires que vous essayez team
et je pense avoir essayé bien des
enfants aux amandes et c'est sûr mais
parce que c'est une façon d'en forme
pimenter un peu sa vie sexuelle team et
aussi si c'est si c'est pas parce que
j'imagine que ça peut être aussi une
manière de gens et j'ai tellement envie
d'aller voir ailleurs
seppi pichon cissé ce je pense que c'est
un peu poètes sous le pif ou je pense
vraiment absolument qu'une règle absolue
de toupet encore une fois c'est tout
l'experte même et il faut que faut que
l'envié d'essayer ce soit égal parce que
c'est les postures faire plaisir à
l'autre le sait c'est une bombe à
retardement la sauce et sur ses skis
après ceux de ses pépites acquis même
part dans le monde barbare d'iphones
nekaies après c'est après que lui les
problèmes mais ça peut jouer dans cette
poule et ça ça ressort après ceux plus
tard puis ça peut paraître s'apprêtait
pas bull mais c'est la compatibilité
sexuelle ces mamans de nice et comme on
a tous des besoins puis c'est de voir
est ce que mes besoins correspondre aux
siens puis après si sa réponse est non
il ya des décisions à prendre part à ce
seul enfant c'est ça la décision enfin
il y en a deux il y en a est ce que je
peux vivre avec ce
il est vraiment capable de s'aligner
avec ses propres limites s'était pas
capable de vivre avec ça c'est correct
mais jeudi il s'est pas pliée dans un
sens où tu sens pas confortable de plier
c'est je pense que c'est vraiment
important de se respecter la dame
s'était tu parle de pratiques avancées
pour avancer je sais pas si on peut
lille c'est plus comme c'est vraiment
une question de besoin de fantasmes qui
de croyance pizza envie d'aller voir
ailleurs pourquoi c'est qu'est-ce que ça
t'apporte rien d'aller voir ailleurs et
au dessus il y en a des fois ci c'est
même pas un manque mais est-ce qu'il y
en a un manque
est ce que tu as envie c'est quoi que tu
as envie d'expérimenter cessé d'aller
creuser plus loin que le besoin que le
sentiment dans le fonds pec mais c'est
une question de compatibilité sexuelle
apprécié c'est comme on est dans
n'importe quoi d'autre je dirais ses
dégoûts cccd préférence qui en a pas
tout et tous ces mêmes préférences fac
c'est vraiment d'être capable de
délimiter ces familles questionnement je
pense que tout le monde est déjà vécu ce
d'une relation qui ont un problème puis
l'espèce de dilemme est ce que c'est un
problème qui est qu'on peut régler ou ce
problème qu'on peut pas régler cette
situation lui vaut la gts que met-on je
termine cette relation ce que je laisse
mon appartement où je travaille deux
fois plus fort pour essayer de contrer
quelque chose pitt sopi c'est une
question qui est excessivement dur à
répondre c'est tout le temps l'espèce de
zone des forces et attire longtemps
cette période le lot après des années de
questionnements des ce que je rentre là
sont le ou non est ce que c'est juste
une passe ce que ça va aller mieux
est ce que ces voiles échec tu subis
j'imagine que des gens quand dans son
bureau avec ce genre de questionnement
le genre est maudit mon partenaire nippo
alignés sur ceux ce comment savoir si
quelque chose qui se travaille ou si si
comme vous êtes vous avez des besoins
vous êtes trop différents il
fonctionnera jamais et je pense qu'il
faut se poser la question d'abord est-ce
qu'ils étaient prêts prête à travailler
et sur ta relation ce que tu en as envie
est ce que tu es trop épuisé pour le
faire ce qui est des fois c'est père
longtemps avant d'aller chercher de
l'aide souvent ça fait longtemps
un conte à des problématiques nom qui
c'est exact fac et si je pense à je
pensais pas mes clientes en particulier
qui avaient commis l'adultère 11 500
journaux sont malheureusement d'état et
qui est tr à s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait beaucoup de ces besoins qui était
pas répondu dans ma relation mais il
était même pas capable 10 ans paris
n'était pas ouvert à la discussion
enfin que le fc ça correspondait pas à
ses valeurs lui d'avoir commis
l'adultère le petit d'avoir trompé son
partenaire qui a senti trop bien avec
elle même soit mais moi j'ai juste de
comprendre que écoute toi des besoins
petit en rendez même pas compte que tu
avais si besoin d'eux donc c'est de
prendre conscience des besoins
qu'est ce que tu veux de quoi tu as
besoin c'est quoi tes valeurs
puis après une fois que définie tout ce
système le bain l'autre peut décider est
ce que ça vaut la peine de continuer oui
ou non c'est cet assaut a pu dire est-ce
que je capable d'avoir cette discussion
avec mon partenaire m'a partenaires oui
non le après c'est plus un facteur à
prendre en considération à travers tout
se disaient qu'est ce que ça vaut la
peine de continuer un peu je pense qu'il
faut faire attention parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sait si les mérites et les
coquilles sur instagram le style est
foutue bat pour ta relation qui est il
faut pas que ce coût était faux petit
mais ce qui est vraiment dany oui le
fait fuiter défaut et les relations qui
sont complètement séduit pas ça ne le
serons complètement incompatible et au
delà les deux misérables malheureux pour
une raison extrêmement simple c'est pis
si je souhaite pas sa personne ni moi ni
mes cauchemars dans ma vie s'il me
réveiller chez pour unités vingt ans
plus tard dans une vie et dans laquelle
quelques malheureux et que ma partenaire
c'est ça fonctionne pour il ya un mur à
nouveau
puis le ch compagnie lan c'est bien
celle des crises qui quitte pas une
[ __ ] c'est une porsche à 600 mhz et
c'est moi c'est mon pire cauchemar ça
d'être tellement juristes ou vente
notamment les soins mais pour ça il faut
prendre soin de sa santé mentale parce
que c'est pas des blocs d'être honnête
avec 6 à la fin je pense qu'ils se faire
des check up mais je suis le premier
coupable déjà même en forme et qu'il
fallait que je m'en fasse juste un
check-up de comac et le thé la pop
pascal fayet des doutes ou y ait des
questionnements il ya des enfants qui
dérange qui sont qu'ils étaient capables
de mettre comme dans le tiroir pu fermer
trois ans puis passée maîtresse dans le
sens qu'il faut vraiment être que ce
3ème année il va d'abord des pivots
explosé mais le garde fermée type tu
penses que tu penses que tu pense
notamment à jos des années plus tard
c'est bête hein venir pis tu es
malheureux n'était pas monté pas où tous
les ans les gens ignorent en début de
relation trop souvent les red flag
mangue et on a tout un cocktail chimique
l'ex passant devant nous le citons la
passion tout l'élan dopamine externe
était terrassé les gens veulent vivre
c'est ce aillleurs qui oublient qu'il ya
des red flag qui sont présents qui c'est
vrai que pendant cette période les bons
libellés avec bonté tous les voies petit
tu vois juste le positif idéalisé cetera
mais si c'est vraiment d'être encore une
fois on est avec toi même la dame de fer
quand il ya des bêtes flag puis il faut
pas les ignorer
souvent je vais faire faire des listes à
mes clientes de leurs besoins en
relation qui je leur fais souligné les
plus importants outils des listes de ta
personne idéale qui le surligner plus
important si j'osais après ce la couleur
des yeux
ben si toi faut vraiment que les yeux
soit breux ok c'est ta priorité mais est
ce que c'est quelque chose sur lequel du
peuplier oui mais les chaussures les
quêtes pu ne veut pas plier fait qu'il
faut en prendre conscience puis quand je
rencontre quelqu'un te rends compte que
ce critère le temps en train de plier
c'est d'être honnête avec toi même par
common à long terme ça marchera pas de
reconsulter se mettant un couteau et
éthique l'isf à qui je m'étais est
important plus là dedans et ce qu'il
sait est ce que la relation que je
revienne vivre concorde mais ton avec ce
que j'ai
être commis 17 rencontres qui finalement
est tous les points que j'avais un ami
deux choses sont importantes pour moyens
nous aucun nixon s'étoffe parce qu'en
fin de semaine j'avais cette
conversation l'appui était est ce que
l'amour peut être suffisante et puis la
réalité moi je pense pas aussi parce que
justement la fatigue mais non mais moi
non plus je pense pas sauf qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui défend des ce point là que
we did est suffisante et puis une fois
tout pouvait se travailler autour de ce
c'est quoi l'amour
voici ce qu'est ce que l'amour est laid
papillon quand la personne rendement
pièces maîtresses qui s'immisçait wes et
ça s'évapore loin ça durait je pense que
deux ans au maximum
oui à ce moment le 8 août et
travaillable assure que deux ans dans
deux langues car ça sent le bois
d'érable dans un trouble de réprimer ce
que tu voulais moi au début c'est
malheureux oui puis on a également quand
j'entends ça me fait frissonner un peu
parce que c'est comme mais je laime ben
oui mais tu est un brent à détruire une
rançon qui ne te convient pas pu la mort
c'est pas il n'y a pas une personne
tombe en amour plusieurs fois d'en
terminer avec plusieurs personnes
différentes
des fois la fête les relations que je
pense que le bon mot technique mais
tonton malsaine des fois ces papillons
leur est plus longtemps c'est parce que
justement il reste un espèce de raie des
bacs à graisse une espèce de d'inconnus
dans un espèce de difficulté qui spécule
t plus on dit hier que ce bout de trois
pilotes et de pacs est passé en à epinal
en pis puis finalement c'est bien plus
intense mais plus montagnes russes
mais c'est un but destructeur aussi de
ces pisse peau avec ce genre de race on
le quitte
je peux te construit quelque chose de
beau de saint d'harmonie ou épicés un
excellent point tu t'amènes c'est parce
que les gens vont mélanger c'est papy
anglais qui sont les papillons souvent
de stress avec l'amour qu'après seuils
sont dans des relations de même au lieu
d'être comme sauter mais le genre on
voit on
rust quitter le bas c'est plate la ligne
droite c'est plat et c'est ça le maudit
problème c'est ça le maudit problème de
la vie c'est que des photos de ligne
droite ça va bien et ici c'est une bonne
équipe que la personne qu'ils crèvent
les papillons enseignants sa gosse c'est
là c'est la magie que tu commences
possiblement vouloir essayer d'avoir une
discussion sur comment est-ce qu'on
pimente le truc commence complet est ce
qu on fait comment est ce qu'on fait que
ces papillons la mairie parce que ce
parce qu'il a ce qu est ce qu un rôle
play mais tentant vauban peuple je fais
comme si on se connaissait pas ou j'aime
les jeunes selon les pompiers
mais voilà avoir cette discussion là
j'imagine pour essayer de voir c'est
comment est-ce qu'on rajoute ce piment
le ouais ouais c'est sûr mais c'est
d'abord dire c'est tellement plus facile
de voir qu'est ce qu'on est potes qu'est
ce qui cloche que d'apprécier qu'est ce
qu'on en pense la cccc le maudit
problème on dirait c'est comme si
pendant quelque chose de grave ils
apprécient quand tu es plus de daf rend
compte à quel point crime
c'était quand même bon finalement t'es
beau ou ccc ccc tout en tout temps se
tait c'est le batteur se battent en
coupe tout à coup vous souhaitez vous
traitez le bateau soit jamais contente
de la décourager
non
[Rires]
non mais je dois personnes non mais je
n'attendrai pas d'expérience à masisi
personnel que ce parce que sam et ont
peut-être qu'à ce moment l'homme prenne
j'essaie de trimer temps de me rappeler
les bons côtés
les pauvres petits délits d apprécier
mais j'imagine que ça doit être assez
comme chez les humains d'être vive une
espèce de satisfaction mais que des fois
même pas raison d'être
ouais c'est vraiment comment l'as tu es
vraiment passionnante à yangzhou mais tu
es comme son ami qui vit seule non mais
t'es comme tu dis il ya moyen d'aller
pimenté ta ta ta relation autrement il
ya des gens qui vont à fos faire vivre
des émotions fortes
ensemble ça fait ça resserre les liens
genre y faire un saut et a osé le il
faut faire trop d'affaires vraiment
comme incroyable et ce pour faire vivre
des émotions qui vont et resserrer les
liens
c'est pour ce qui est des sentiments
sont comme décupler le caecum se passe
par forte c'est parce qu'elle allait
faire un saut en parachute avec
quelqu'un le dise bien rush d'adrénaline
avec la personne qui vient de vivre le
même rouge que toi le coach prend dans
ses bras après le pilote est comme mon
meilleur petit comprendre quand on
respire le divine resserrer l'élite
bon c'est clair que c'est la chimie tu
le dit un des autres justement aux dîmes
c'est le meilleur exemple je n'avais
jamais pensé à ça comme ça mais au final
c'est clair que c'est ce qui se passe
parce que c'était aulas en moto du zig
zag d'un chan reek les montagnes partout
autour le plus beau paysage au monde
pilotes de la quelqu'un et puis ça fait
juste reçu des semences alignement
liliane mairie puis mangé une deuxième
terrible du pur
la valider ou d'invalider des pressions
aussi que c'est moi personnellement
justement les émotions les plus intenses
que j'ai vécu c'est des situations qui
étaient souvent un peu malsaine mais qui
était que quelqu'un comme privés un peu
d'avoir ce que je veux autant que je le
veux at il indiqué mettant quelqu'un qui
serait pas 100% réceptif ou quelqu'un
qui serait indisponible pour une raison
mais que c'est pas classe ou itunes on
en a plus on dirait que tu veux plus
autres vues qui aimait tant à audi
notamment accès à la personne de manière
courte qui en voudrait plus pilote toute
date dans ta tête
cette personne là parce que tandis que
la réalité quand tu habites avec ton ta
partenaire c'est tout le temps avec
amman et c'est le contraire le temps de
terminer derrière le tout a besoin de
prendre prendre un break mais faussement
l'utérus il est que le fait d'être privé
un peu de soi recherche en gelant fois
plus mince et c'est seulement ça arrive
dans la vie même pensé une rupture qui
se laisse ton ta partenaire petit souci
que si tu reviens mais matin la personne
veut le voir le jour cette personne ne
passera plus jamais accessible qu'à
penser à d'autres choses
au moins 18 mois
parce que choix c'est plutôt choix
depuis droit de veto sur ce qui se
passait enfin que je pense que c'est
aussi ça vient comme ça vient rajouter
un peu de l'autrement question de titre
le bon choix ce que j'entends rien à
regretter ce que j'aurais su j'aurais
tout eu beau du cc gondrand marty
questionnement le qui font vivre des
émotions en dedans et on a tellement
peur dû régler les humains qui suscite
une émotion qui veut rendre désagréable
régressive moi je vais toujours ensemble
avec ni nick and com qu'est-ce qu'est ce
que tu regretterait puis fais pas ce que
je pense que vous regretterez c'est
comme l'émotion ou les la sensation la
plus comme vous je regrette été
impuissant impuissante
quand il dut régressé je suis d'accord
mais des fois j'ai l'impression que
met-on si c'est vraiment voir le verre à
moitié vide mais j'apprécie inquiet si
je reste avec mon partenaire jeu vos
jeux
pour vivre une telle expérience que je
vais regretter mais si je puis ma
partenaire devraient regretter de tête
avec 30 grand défi c'est comme si ton
c'est du blues loustau et sean nautique
propose que je fais je voudrais
greetings fax et luck étape cycliste
avec tes besoins et qui va leur rentrer
en ligne de compte qui fait qu'un faux
je m'écoute c'est dans la vie faut que
staline avec toi même le pot avec les
autres pas avec ce que les autres
pensent si je pense que c'est là que tu
prends ton recul puis que tu fais
vraiment une introspection
c'est pourtant en faire s'est dit peu
importe que ce soit en relation dans ta
profession est dans ta vie familiale peu
importe c'est tellement important de
faire d introspection qui oui ça se peut
que tu as eu un sentiment de regret mais
le sentiment de soulagement peut-être
encore plus grande si en tant que maman
décédée capable de gérer ses émotions et
mes supposés petits mettons-le
aujourd'hui à 30 ans tt1 chaque
expérience que tu vis chaque relation
site apprend c'est que tu apprends sur
toi tu apprends ce jeu aussi commander
lit avec une autre personne petit répit
sera meilleur que j'étais mes chaussons
ou mieux que des fois on soual du moyen
soit comme attirés vers quelque chose
qui équipent à saintes qui destructeur
pour lui versus quelque chose qui qui
qui est tombée je pense juste pour tous
parce que je pose la question
identitaire
en tout je suis je sais pas le jeu posé
la question à combien tu y mettons tout
le monde tout le monde autour de touléco
poteau de nous qu'on voit piqué c'est
tout un bol il ya des gens qui restent
ensemble billet c'est des choix c'est
des choix salariés aux choix que tu fais
pour toi même tu sais je pense qu'on se
compare beaucoup aussi les autres puis
les autres dont l'air de pion dans l'air
de tout le monde fait sexe comme quatre
fois par jour
confirmant la course confie sa part fait
quatre fois par année mais tout le monde
en fait quatre fois par jour fait que
d'être rude qu'en quatre fois par année
je pense qu'on est dans une société où
on se compare énormément et que nos
choix deviennent plus tellement nos
choix on est vraiment un t1 influencé
par notre façon prendre des décisions
etc
fact et je pense que c'est de faire
attention à tout ça quand tu me prends
des décisions pour toi dans ta vie tu
sais je pense je pense aussi qu'il ya
une pression sociale si tu parles tu te
dis j'arrive à 30 ans mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire pour toi arriver le nom
mais je vais pas le thé mais ton jeux
plus matures
je suis plus je me connais mieux
beaucoup plus à 30 ans qu'à 20 ans c'est
vraiment beaucoup plus mais je comprends
si ce que tu faisais 4 entend souvent ça
rime avec le faut je me cause il faut
que je fasse il faut que je commence à
penser aux enfants de se c'est sûr que
c'est le genre en arrière de ma tête
mais moi ce que je veux dire c'est juste
avec les expériences maintenant
justement des relations que j'arrêtais
mardi soir les red flag mais bruit comme
le brûle puis le cas mais qu'a t on
jamais vu je n'ai jamais vu une telle
voix pour et puis le foot et vivent une
fois un ca de l'opt et le je peux pas
croire que j'ai pas vu ce pack crois que
j'ai tout à fait ce que les antennes qui
s'égayent spi quand tu vois la bonne
neige commence à rouler maalot et plus
étaient plus outillés pour en sortir
mais tue le temps que sur la peau vécu
tu peux pas savoir effectuer six ans
mais ceux ci c'est parce que tu as vécu
ces sentiments lui aussi quelqu'un ou
pour savoir comment ça revenait ton
corps enregistre les sensations pour les
expériences pas quand il va voir comment
au monde et quand je la dérange avec
comme seul moteur le g2x c'était paul
von si c'est pas les une place dans une
direction qui était agréable faqir
jogoth
c'est ce que je pense que avec la vie
avec le temps on prend de l'expérience à
travers nos expériences c'est ce qu'ils
vont nous moulé en tant qu'être humain
je pense qu'il faut pas taper sur la
tête quand on reste dans des relations
qui sont pas bonnes pour nous on qu'on
fait des choix qui sont polis bon je
parlais de regret tantôt c'est quand
même normal d'en vivre de regrets mais
c'est pas ça va nous pousser à des
personnes encore plus meilleur encore
mais pour ce qui pour ce qui a rapport
avec les règles et un regret j'essaie
activement aujourd'hui en vie de tous
les jours de jeu jamais en avoir parce
que il ya aucune décision
ces mets ton quand tu prends une
décision il pue c'est fini la vision est
pris
oui nous avons un regret ça sert à rien
ça amènera nulle part ça vaut rien
changé depuis
effectivement fait juste d'essayer de
changer de mindset de doit finalement à
regrets ça sert à rien c'est juste un
sentiment qu'on s'impose qui est
temporaire qui négatif qui nous fait
ruminer sur quelque chose à place de
l'est de laventie mais ce pacte mindset
a essayé de changer je tends processus
dossier de change de sens au monde
ouais ouais parce qu'après cm prend des
décisions après ce souci c'est qu'on se
lance plus c'est une beauté d'un statu
quo comme ce bail prend pas de décision
comme ce seront 6 pas de ma faute si tu
ressens des émotions négatives ou atx
été ratée mais moi je pense que c'est
vrai c'est je pense qu'il faut que mais
faut se forcer à prendre comme un peu de
trac et notre esprit à a pu avoir ce
sentiment lui parce qu'il dit quand tu
descends la liste des décisions qu'on a
prise des décisions on en prend à toutes
les fractions de seconde le danvic sud
et sans la liste des fois que j'aurais
pas dû faire ça ben malice paraître
longue en tabarnak puis au final titre
que des six entreprises termine lorsque
tu es maintenant fait que ça change
comme rien n'est d'abord à regret par
rapport à x ou y une relation passée des
ouvrages réduit voire livre est la gamme
et non parce que maintenant sur les
boîtes aurait pas pu les voir avant
passe d agiter n'avais jamais vécu un
temps souvient tintamarre qui
m'apprécient de s'appuyer s'apitoyer sur
son sort et j'aurais produit le ruminer
sa salariée manger un peu une allergie à
eau
on a déjà réduit ses dépens en trainde
était pas ma solution car je résume
cette série n 6 qui peut nécessairement
la meilleure chose pour toi fac je pense
que c'est des femmes 180 par comme garde
c'est bon là je me retrousse les manches
qui s'était pas aligné avec avec mes
objectifs c'est quoi mes objectifs
auxquels est qu on s'en va dans cette
direction
c'est fou comment tout ce qu'on tout ce
qu'on dit [ __ ] tomber tant par rapport
à
aux relations de part en part à bien se
connaître en relation pour savoir
croître qu'est ce que tu dis que si tu
veux pas ça fait vraiment un cercle
jusqu'à jusqu'à la sexualité qu'on
parlait tant tous les 30 reconnaissant
tout moment même en écrivant une liste
de choses que tu veux ainsi le ca est la
meilleure façon de prendre des décisions
éclairées et puis d'aller de l'avant de
la façon qui fait qu'on dirait que les
deux enfants sont donc c'est un peu ça
fonctionne un peu la même façon le type
ou c'est ta santé sexualité je dépends
tôt prendre ça prend soin de sa santé
physique sa santé mentale
mais sa santé sexuelle si ça passe par
la découverte de soi sais tu peux pas
demander à quelqu'un d'autre de
découvrir ton corps à ta place quelqu'un
d'autre de prendre en fait de n'importe
quelle santé tu peux demander à
n'importe quelle personne ne prendra
pour cassante est à ta place maintenant
sept concernent maintenant on parle
l'entraînement et est quelqu'un qui peut
gérer vos corps et va courir c'est beau
mais c'est parce que c'est toi qui vont
en voir les conséquences d'accidents
n'importe quoi c'est comme ça je pense
on parle de relation puis j'ai une
question mettons mettons qu'on qu'on
recule puis on regarde sud de plus loin
on parle d'éthique aux membres une
relation saine et mettons
qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils aient décidé
que la manière de vivre c'était des
relations mais tant pis s que la
monogamie
c'est le meilleur système dont selon toi
c'est je pense que le couple est une
institution de danse ou et qui a décidé
ce la religion de l avait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de pouvoirs sur
comment on allait gérer nos vies vivent
nos vies donc bon les femmes n'étant
peut est capable d'aller travailler peu
capable c'est vraiment pas le bon mot on
est un peu il y avait par ailleurs
permission gars y'a pas la permission
d'aller travailler mais il fallait que
quelqu'un les faces b l'homme fait que
l'homme fait prenait à sa charge une
femme qui errent en retour allait lui
offrir des enfants pour pouvoir
continuer de faire tourner la terre
parce que ben ça prends tes enfants pour
par l'état 10 heures à travailler avec
eux on se mettait à 2 pour parce qu'un
homme ça ces petites îles pour un homme
défend arrive plus qu'une femme que l'on
rentre dans la monogamie
on rentre dans l'institution du mariage
qui était jusqu'à temps que tu meures
que je marron ceux qui pleins de l'autre
c'est comme cette rencontre qui avait
pas tout le temps d' amour de l'amour
dans les mariages - souvent qu'autrement
vinci sortie mais c'est comme se fût
institutions des enfants je te fais à
manger
c'est un échange de service quasiment
abouti fois que je pense que la
monogamie vient de le est-ce que c'est
la meilleure formule pour les êtres
humains
je pense qu'elles les cas seulement il
est très bon et même pas c'est tellement
difficile pour tellement de gens
l'impression ti de l'entente des
histoires des autres ont été mariées 60
ans comme si c'était l'exploiter puis
qui justement tillet tellement de me
tourner au mariage qui brisent ya
tellement aussi souvent de d'adultère
qui commit plus je mets des guillemets
parce que si je peux pas de jugement là
dessus mais j'ai l'impression que c'est
moins ça c'est difficile la monogamie
quand même c'est un choix c'est vraiment
un choix
sérieusement c'est un choix inconscient
qu'on fait parce qu'il ya des gens le
pire des gens qui commencent à terre on
parle le polyamour et on parle de tous
ses concepteurs
je pense le mcg est reconnue types de
monstres mais voyons donc je respecte
trop jaloux jeunes mais mais c'est quoi
toi toi qui est en relation peu plus
aucune pulsion pour personne s'était
nettement mais comme la planche de bord
la boule spawn moi aimons et des zags de
pulsions le on est c pour la survie de
théologie titrait essentialise dans mon
discours pour la survie la race humaine
qu'est qu'on s'est reproduit qu'on a
envie de se reproduire piquer ses fans
comme je dis encore une fois c'est très
socialiste mais mais je pense que c'est
sûr si si je pense à bord de la chaussée
s'est laissé la question parce que c'est
tellement parce que c'est une question
qui m'habite beaucoup dans depuis depuis
peut-être les derniers mois le puits
c'est difficile à mettre le doigt
précisément sur la jalousie puis qu'est
ce que c'est puis pourquoi est ce que ça
existe
puis qu'est ce qu'il créé puis puis plus
j'y pense plus
ce que ça port de toi parce que parce
que tu étais la seule personne que ça
que ça dérange juxta occupent ou que ça
je m'exprime vraiment mal en ce moment
mais on dirait que montrer que la
jalousie c'est juste le pire feeling
c'est le père feeling au monde
je connais pas de pire feeling que ce
puits on seul impose à nous mêmes parce
qu'une fois que tu let go de wever tt
pujal outils moi ça m'est déjà arrivé
dans mon lit le plus d'avoir une boule
dans le ventre parce qu'il aimait ma
blonde ou la personne que je fréquente
était dans un bar où étaient armés de
bâtons les peluches avec ceux de creuser
le plus j'avais une boule dans le ventre
lépi le pilat ça m'empêchait de dormir
puis ça me rendait fou tu y es au final
j'étais la seule raison pourquoi ça me
rendait fou tu parce que c'est moi qui
me l'imposé puis une fois qui
déconstruit ce c'est comme on dirait que
ça devient on dirait que mettons le
polyamour pis la pelure aux gammes s'y
coller et élimine polygamie ou plus haut
ouais la polygamie on dirait que ça
devient de plus en plus dans ma tête une
façon mais un concept derrière lequel je
peux je peux me placer parce que parce
qu'on dirait que ça enlève de l'équation
la jalousie qui le père feeling c'est
les gens qui sont dans les couplets
pauli gut est trop peu importe le
comment ils veulent définir seul à
chacun sa façon de le définir
mais il y en a eu de la jalousie on
ressent la jalousie à partir de l'âge de
deux mois ça me prend ton petit marteau
en bois
égoutter et qu'un jeu c'est pas qu'à moi
tu en manges pas avec toi ou répond par
des bergers deux mois la séance est très
jeune
est à peine eu le temps d'ouvrir le
monde sur 100 déjà la jalousie je pense
que c'est un sentiment qui est très
humain même les animaux le sentiment qui
est qui être vivant dans son le temps un
chien mais dont souffre la tension ne
retombe pas c'est une constance dans le
fond ouais ouais c'est vrai puis je
pense que les gens qui sont dans ces
formules de relations leur ressemble
quand même et c'est des gens qui vont
pas laisser ses sentiments le guide et
gérer leurs attitudes leurs actions ou
leur décision mais c'est ça prend un
grand travail sur soi j'ai vraiment
lâché sur moi j'ai le feeling que ça
encore une fois ce que c'est vraiment sa
peur de toi parce que citoyen dont de
confiance à 100% en toi bien ce que tu
vaux la jalousie comme plus lieu d'être
je pensais d'être distancé dès ce qui
peut être personnel à toi tu ne pas
prendre personnel qu'est ce que parce
qu'elle est la priorité allait à la
france envers quelqu'un d'autre que ce
soit sexuelle émotionnel que sa part
rapport avec toi si tu n'y aucune
distance je pense par rapport à tout ça
pour être capable de vraiment l'intégrer
faire des biens avec ça mais encore une
fois on n'y peut on n'est pas des comme
ça
ouais moi j'ai pas l'impression qui est
justement quand tu ouvres la porte ou
polyamour jeu pendant que ça simplifie
les affaires au contrat j'ai
l'impression de faire comme 15 ans soit
deux fois meilleur faut que
c'est caca c'est pas une option c'est
mettons moi quand je décide d un
végétarien je me suis maintenant la
viande n'est plus d'options je sais pas
une photo datant pour une fauche à
laisser porter s'est jamais été comme ça
l'idée me traverse pas l'esprit
moi c'est pas quelque chose que je peux
me faisais à en fin de semaine je me
sentais un petit jet j'ai pas de
régression une théorie encore une fois
que ouvrir la porte
mettons à je veux pas pressé de
l'infidélité n'est pas ce que ça peut
donner sens que si c'est un jeu d elle
mais je te mets à l'ati a beaucoup plus
ouvert au palais hameau tout ce que ça
peut peut-être faire en sorte qu' après
ce tu désires plus où qu'ils soient plus
présentes le recherchent plus piqué
finalement cette éloigne de ton
appartement
penses tu ai je pas sûr que j'ai compris
ce qui est rien de violence
est-ce que tu as l'impression que ça
peut faire en sorte que tu disais à
quitter opus aller voir ailleurs c'est
mettons que six moutons qui le contrat
implicite avec mon partenaire c'est la
fidélité pic est un concept que tu
questionne nos quotidiens étudiants qui
s'est sortie sans guillemets ça qui fait
est ce que que je fais que je fais de
plein de mon plein gré pour le bien de
la relation de ce jeu c'est pas s'ouvrir
la porte
des fois ça peut pas causé plus de tort
que de quelques 10 6 6 mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut absolument que
ce soit dans que tout le monde soit 100
% à l'aise avec avec cette idée là
dessus ça ça me sert se met vraiment à
100% se soit pliée c'est comme si on
faisait un tour pour les traits pas trop
si c'est comme si pendant un temps ce
n'était pas confortable de plier si
vraiment ces gens là vont vraiment
toujours réitéré les règles du jeu je
pense que c'est là la clé
je pense que justement faut pas que ça
devienne flou l'espèce de
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait déjà en le
jetant n'ai pas parlé où sont les
toilettes on le fait les deux avec
quelqu'un d'autre mais loge une fois
aussi un tempo loges des fêtes être
quelqu'un d'autre mais c'est quoi la
différence dans le fond dans 91 le ya un
flou au plus haut niveau des règles qui
régissent le couple je pense vraiment
que c'est là qu'est qu'un problème c'est
fac est vraiment que ça prend plus
qu'une fois que tu dis ok mettons la
règle implicite de notre coupe c'est la
fidélité pics et seube après cela
discussion est un peu réglé peut-être
car ouvrir le peut-être ouvrir un jour
subil besoins liés
mais quand tu joues avec ce concept là
je pense que justement faute au temps
pas vraiment beaucoup plus pro que
direct par claire pour poté des
malentendus qui est piquée de finalement
de confiance qu'ils soient brisés
finalement mais sans même way ou du toit
justement déculpabilisant 10 ans betty
dans le fond c'est pas un spoiler pour
le fait une fois nos notes parce que je
mets une grande grande grands le concept
la confiance dans ce type de relation le
est vraiment au coeur je pense des
fonctionnements le sopi la communication
je pensais de toujours c'est le
sentiment de jalousie dont on parle
tantôt hills en parlent entre eux 1
ça me fait quelque chose cette personne
me suis dit c'est corey excès de style
c'est d'être transparent transparente
par rapport qui s'est pas de réagir par
rapport à l'enjeu à la jalousie essayé
beaucoup de de se rassurer dans ces
dossiers dans les discussions par comme
énoncé j'apprécie quand même ta présence
m'apporte quelque chose c'est pis encore
une fois ses distances et ptt
qu'est ce qu'un look j-pop sais si c'est
parce que c'est vraiment juste de miser
sur ce qu'il ya de bon dans le lien dans
la connexion entre les personnes puis de
profiter de ce sens comparer je pense
que c'est la règle du pur ait d'arriver
dans toutes les conversations avec voici
maria comment moi je me sens par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé ou par rapport à ce
que tu me dis ou par rapport à ce qu'on
fait puis juste de le mettre centre de
partir de l'été d'autre en fait le beau
geste pour les la plus polyamours ou à
l'erreur
arriverez vous dirai ça ça me fait me
sentir cette façon leur confession
qu'est ce qu'on fait à partir de là
c'est dur d'être parce que le problème
qui arrive c'est qu'il n'y en ait pas
100% honnête
en fait on n'est jamais 100% jamais 100%
mais des fois tu vas rencontrer
quelqu'un plus tu veux bien paraître
fait que tu lis qu'il est le montrent
certains traits certaines positions
certains aient pignon que peut-être tu
laisses de plus de côté certaines façons
qui était tout et que this is it was
charmante il faut le voir à ce jeu
tellement que plus voir mes photos
personnes comparé à tout bateau tape à
leur portée où débute après ceux de
celle d'amener ce qui m'a plu je pense
que plus on attend plus difficile d'être
100% comme moi c'est quand le métier
défaut des moments j'étais le plus
honnête avec des partenaires c'est comme
au moment de la genre de séparation
parce que tu es comme plus rien à perdre
et et puis des fois je t'aime à le fait
c'est rare jusque là où est ce que
l'autre c'est comme qui dit vraiment à
tout
des fois il faut six à la fête comme des
clics et des affaires puis finalement
comme consigne faire un bout de chemin à
faire mais si ceux-ci des dépôts de tout
temps par cas sur 10 c'est comment
qu'avoir rage et puis je vois tu la
perds du jeudi se tait jamais 100% toi
il ya une experte en relations
amoureuses et je pense que docteur ce
colloque
je peux certain de son titre mais à
s'appelle est à repérer tiens c'est
vraiment penchés sur la question de
l'infidélité de au sein des couples et
du désir sexuel qui est halal explique
que souvent les couples ou l'infidélité
puis des coupes qui continuent de
vouloir rester ensemble malgré ces
événements là et il ya des breaks trop
dans le sens où les partenaires vont
vivre chacun leur côté des
insatisfactions sens en parler y en a un
qui va sauter la clôture qui va se
permettre de vivre ces expériences là
qui se passe et on va blanc mais cette
personne leur puis on veut vraiment
mettre comme le projecteur sur ce que
cette personne a vécu mais l'autre
personne qui restait fidèle
puis qui était malheureuse dans la
station le t elle aussi à la main à dire
des choses pas tout un geste la personne
qui sont la clôture le quai qui a fait
fait qu'il y avait des insatisfactions
sait même pas toujours parce que des
insatisfactions que les gens et moins
voyagent pas que c est ce qu a dit
c'était comme souvent il ya des coupes
qui une fois qu'ils aient eu
l'infidélité c'est comme s'il y avait un
site et une deuxième rallonge une
relation d'embarquer là on peut se dire
les vraies affaires l'on peut se dire
j'ai pas été satisfaites sexuellement
l'on peut se dire que j'étais tanné
qu'on soit dans notre outil d'analysé
l'on peut c'est petit c'est comme ça
l'année débreak tout alors qu'on devrait
tellement tout le temps faire ce mais on
ne peut on n'apprend pas ceux à l'école
on en n'est pas éduqué on est on est on
apprend comment faire des maths 4,36 je
pense que c'est puis se passe dans une
fois mais repasse en mode économie
familiale
c'est un vrai débat sauf dernière viande
je pense que on n'est vraiment pas
équipé on est expulsé par lui est ce que
si j'ai l'impression que la fidélité et
comme souvent un doigt de valeur suprême
noté dans les relations psicom alors moi
si mon chat mousse ma blonde me trompe
c'est sûr que c'est fini je pourrai
jamais pensé par dessus est-ce qu'on
accorde trop d'importance à l'est d'el
tissot nantua où ça dépend
mais la fidélité peut peut prendre c'est
pas juste une fidélité de pas aller voir
ailleurs mais tant la fidélité comme je
l'entends père me sens plus large c'est
aussi 2 si tu vas voir ailleurs tu viens
chez nous tout d'après tu me le dis on
s'en parle c'est la fidélité c'est aussi
d'être fidèle à quelqu'un pas
nécessairement juste physiquement lui de
faire jeu fidèle à notre relation je
suis fidèle à toi puis si on fait
quelque chose on a la conviction de
suite je pense que dans ce sens large la
fidélité c'est paul et pas sur values et
les mettons je connaissais différence
entre mettons une relation qui va bien
vraiment soudée pilule pour une raison x
est un où elle est partie c'est un
congrès une fois puis
bon finalement celui-ci le gars sa
chambre si wade veut mais mes jambes on
y mentionne une différence en quelque
chose qui arrive une fois puis on s'en
parle compense par dessus versus il
mardi soir avec les enfants puis je sais
pas où est ce que l'autre et puis arrive
en 3 heures du matin tout croche le tipi
en tant que gérant la pression qui était
chaque situation sont sont vraiment
vraiment de faire il ya un fil même une
trilogie de films que j'aime vraiment
tout c'est quoi la télé les cetc sur un
couple qui dans le premier film
francophone
ils raconteront 23 ans est en fait un
système de vents plus tard qu'est les
acteurs et les personnages avaient
trente deux ans puis en fait un autre
film devant plus tard quand les acteurs
et les personnages avec 41 ans facs et
les deux mêmes personnes à trop stade de
leur vie trois stades différentes et
avec dans le premier cinq ans dans le
2ème sont rendus ou est ce qu'ils sont
dans une voie plus tard fait se retrouve
un peu le pied en 3e sont sont ensemble
ses pieds la troisième fut une grosse
grosse chicane à ce que c'est moche mais
je trouve ces femmes leur fascinant pour
comme étudier une ration de coupe je
trouve ça tellement vrai qui choque
était vraiment beaucoup de gens pour
regarder ses mails puis se reconnaître
dans certains traits d'un ou l'autre qui
a manié bon et chicanes ses fans
d'histoires courtes legault dans le film
et il ya vraiment il tombe en amour ce
film il ya laissé sa vie aux états unis
déménager en france pour pour être avec
elle
le lien de famille avec elle tu y ailles
investi tout ça toute sa vie à sa
famille à ses fils qui a affecté les
scans qui a titré la file une telle dont
l'assistant lequel quitte à valider beau
petit courriel de la nana à tous ceux
ayant dit le type il est fait comme il
fait si la question se pose si je suis
si j'ai un commitment pour notre couple
à 100% tir tactique il veut pas le dire
mais déclare marc bellemare avait même
temps c'est vrai que 99.999 % du temps
est investi
tout son sens aux normes dans son côté
dans mettons dans ce genre de situation
comme ceux est ce que une affaire pour
être un derby que c'est ça je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui sont vraiment et
qui ont des opinions vraiment arrêté par
rapport à l'infidèle des jusqu'à temps
de le vivre ces séquences de vie et des
gens qui vont leur opinion va continuer
d'être arrêté il ya des gens qui vont
faire comme qui a terminé peut-être que
on a des choses à travailler peut-être
que tu es tellement de raisons pour
lesquelles quelqu'un peut commettre
l'infidélité
il y en a qui vont connaître la vie des
petits pas sont heureux heureuse avec
leurs partenaires mais que sexuellement
boy comme une petite fife accueilleront
je cherchais la satisfaction qu'ils
veulent ailleurs il y en a qui vont
commettre l'infidélité propre ils font
ça pour rester dans la relation le parce
que tout le reste cela leur convient
c'est après ce est ce que le mieux
serait d'avoir une discussion de
regarder c'est quoi des solutions
peut-être y en a qui vont commettre
infidélité pour ce faire l'essai non
qu'ils savent comment quitter la
relation donc espère se faire prendre un
film et je pense oui mais des
associations il y avait un film avec mon
système - les noms de films et non
l'acteur je m'engage dans quelque chose
mais ils ferment leur gueule
il est avec sa femme depuis des années
il vaut à l'épicerie d'année puis
rencontre une fille puis comme ça clique
foule mais le parce que puis il trompe
la femme avec qui depuis des années avec
la fille qui il ya cette auto saboter la
relation fait et ça marche pas parce que
s'accroche lascaux puis un bon tennis je
disais ok je t'es trompé c'est bon j'ai
trompé plus ils pensent bien celle
délivrée le d'une relation le la ficome
au québec on en parle et qui le chien
s'est passé le but mais j'ai vraiment
des gens qui vont comme qui vont que m
l'infidélité pour se sortir de certaines
situations il faut y mettre un bémol des
foyers juste du monde qui deviennent
insupportables juste pour savoir les
sympas sont pas capables de dire
et si la nouvelle est ce que tu mets des
raisons pour lesquelles quelqu'un peut
commettre un petit et après ça c'est de
voir je pense que tu peux pas te
prononcer là dessus tant que tu le
peuvent vécu qui malheureusement on va
souvent la personne qui est comme une
infidélité comme la personne des membres
de la relation le lester zack moss leur
site une personne mais non je dis il y
avait un système lourd dans la relation
le kiki qui est créé qui peut-être que
la personne qui est comme une infidélité
alors essayé de te parler avant de le
farsi
ping si tu vois ma cliente que je
parlais tantôt elle essaye de parler le
à laisser y aller c'est ya les seuils et
pot d'ouverture avec le moment donné ça
a été de dire ok ben le de fait sur ses
contres des valeurs mais mais là
pourquoi tu risques dans le fond c'est
le l'as tu te rends pas tout en compte
le canton comme et ses 6 6 3 pas quand
commis ces gestes et le nom c'est parce
que je me disais je juste d'être un peu
tout un conte de type besoin de titre on
peut tout un conte qui sont peu répondu
fakher le pour hyacinthe et mégots
introspection que tu vois à y écrit une
lettre dans laquelle a lieu tous dit
qu'ils étaient comme c'est sûr qu'il va
mal réagi et c'est ce qui va mariage est
ce qu a eu un break tout y avait un vrai
que pour une fois dans sa vie il a été
capable de l'écouté et les télés sont en
train de décider comment commence qui
vont ils vont vivre
est ce que c'est une construction
sociale d'allier partenaire de vie avec
sexualité parce qu'il met donc reprendre
plusieurs exemples pour revenir à ma
question
mais donc on n'est pas les seuls êtres
vivants qui se met qui trouve un
partenaire de vie mettons les pingouins
les ans la gelée pas les empereurs
celles qui sont avec un partenaire toute
leur vie tes pie ix à dieu une personne
dans ma vie qui était papa et maman
modèle mais qui avec qui je parlais
souvent que des plus vieux pas mal payé
lui m'avait déjà dit que lui avec sa
femme
qui avait deux enfants qui était la
femme de sa vie puis dix mois sme a fait
ramené à et soul dans un bar t puis a
sauté par un guide son bureau si paul ça
ne change rien que la relation que j'ai
avec eric que cela la femme de ma vie la
mère de mes enfants mon partenaire de
witte et faites-lui tegra2 vraiment
séparer la sexualité et son parti sont
sa relation de couple qui dernièrement
je côtoie aussi du monde que si ce
qu'ils vivent comme ce puits qui sont
100% bien avec ce concept le matériau
est ce que ma question c'est est-ce que
c'est une création sociale qu'ont au
dessus qu'on a mis les deux ensembles
picon qui sont indissociables maintenant
mais c'est sans arrêt à toute l'histoire
de la monogamie de sa porte et la
reproduction se sait pas si longtemps
que ce que la notion du plaisir est
vraiment et qu'on creuse vraiment dans
la notion du plaisir quand on parle de
sexualité et si la sexualité c'est elle
avait des fonctions reproductives c'est
même là la définition de l'om et je
pense que oui mais au niveau de la
sexualité il y avait même pas la notion
plaisir 6 séries comme fais que je pense
qu'ils étaient ça ça provient de le losc
est une construction si je pense que je
pense que du moment que tu es bien avec
avec comment tu vis ta sexualité que ce
soit de façon monogame que ce soit de
façon ouverte
je pense que c'est ce qui est important
y'en a qui vont souvent parce que
souvent mettons dans tout ce qu'ils
construction sociale souvent on évalue
notre propre confort par rapport à une
situation x ou y selon les normes de la
société ici pis si on est capable de
déconstruire en tête les normes cette
société lance d'annoncer une
construction sociale qui existe ballon
réalise qu au final ce qu'on pensait
qu'ils étaient notre zone de confort et
plus confortables c'est le même principe
mais ton qu'avec quelqu'un qui est qui
et qui est bisexuelle mettons que toute
sa vie a construit son confort en se
disant par andy dans most avec des
femmes mettons un game watch avec des
femmes parce que
parce que c'est la norme parce que parce
que la constitution sociale c'est ce
couple là qui existent mais qu'elle
réalise qu'à qui n'ont finalement
mettons-la l'hétérosexualité est une
construction sociale à l'orientation
sexuelle est une construction sociale au
final c'est un spectre d'un million
d'affaires puis qui réalise qu'une fois
que ce soit ici des constructions de
vision les déconstruire réalise que son
confort existe beaucoup plus dans ces
écoutes et l'humain je savais de sens le
fait c'est sûr que si mais ton on se dit
mais en fait esclave
au final la question tourne en rond
parce que le confort qui soit une
création social non reste aussi
confortable dont je pense que c'est ça
je pense qu'il ya des normes qui sont là
depuis tellement longtemps
puis on fait juste on les remet pas en
question il ya des gens là qui commence
à vraiment plus les remettre en question
je pense que les réseaux sociaux ont
vraiment un impact à ce sujet là parce
que les gens qui ont une idéologie vont
aller à la rencontre d'autres personnes
sur la planète qui ont la même idéologie
chaque lot ont lieu comme des mouvements
qui se créent le par rapport à tout ça
mais je pense qu'il y ait des normes qui
sont là depuis longtemps qui proviennent
de la religion qui proviennent du
système patriarcal ecce terra qui bat
qui mérite d'être questionné si toi tu
es une personne qui a envie de
questionner puis de remettre en question
puisse vraiment aller dans
l'introspection il est peut-être
profiter dans les petites boîtes khl
compte quand on sait qu on me dit tu
devrais quitter la dent là dedans
betty je pense c'est tout à ton honneur
et d'un autre côté si toi les normes ça
fait on en faire quitter bien là-dedans
battant les fautes hostilités ce soir à
beijing ça revient ce qu'on disait
plutôt qu'il est se connaître soi même
puis trouver de la manière de vivre dans
le passé ce qui est différente pour
différents personne ne peut penser
qu'ils raisonnent les plus de 8 ans à
toul servette où jouera surtout de
revient c'est fou parlons un peu de ton
podcast avec 45 michel les brass
expression que ça s'arrête qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est quoi la mission
c'est quoi la mission derrière ce pack à
cela c'est quoi l'objectif c'est quoi
vos sujets qu'est ce que c'est de
normaliser les discussions entourant la
sexualité des tabous viser un nouveau
mot et
les justement toutes les caisses qui est
autour de la sexualité et de prendre des
gens qui sont experts experts de leur
propre vie qdv qui sont experts dans
leur propre vécu
ouais c'est bon ouais parce qu'elle est
t on
comment dire j'aime cette société
experte de ton propre vécu dans le sang
signifie un lieu de vie tout aussi ce
qui sauve et c'est déjà qu'ils vont
venir et qui vont avoir comme la la la
la générosité de venir nous nous
témoigner de la réalité
puis ça s'est tellement précieux parce
que ces réalités le bain même si on n'en
parle pas beaucoup
elles sont erratiques sont présentes au
travers des êtres humains
puis la sexualité c'est tellement tabou
on en parle tellement beau à ces
attaques lui j'ai l'impression que les
hommes en parle plus ensemble eh ben
j'ai l'impression que beaucoup nous du
moins plus jeunes en gros on en parlait
tout le temps nous mettons en jeu de
façon intelligente la même façon c'est
pas convaincu mais vous autres tout en
impression qui est en déficit hydrique
c'est pour ce soir bordeaux vraiment il
était recherché dans un nouveau en fait
émerger un tournage avec nouveau cadre
qui est un organisme qui qui veut offrir
de l'éducation sexuelle pour les jeunes
sur les réseaux sociaux
puis je vais parler de la masturbation
qui est on me demande et toi t'en parler
dessus avec des amis quand j'étais jeune
puis moi je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
jamais filtres par rapport à ceux et
pourtant mes parents c'était un artiste
est bien normal rien de normal est
anormal mais c'était pas un sujet qu'on
parlait au sud
non c'est le dépôt mais j'ai jamais eu
de filtres par rapport à 7 puis je sais
pas d'où ça sort je pense que j'ai
vraiment juste une curiosité naturelle
pour ces choses là mais moi j'en parle
et là mes amis j'ai comme toi sur ce
entité en forte à ce niveau look i fakty
mais moi personnellement j'en ai
toujours parlé aux gens autour de moi
que j'ai toujours créé des discussions
autour de ces sujets là mais je me rends
compte que c'est vraiment un pollock
pied c'est beaucoup les femmes on ne
gomme pas eu d espace pour en parler
on n'a pas eu des espaces pour pourrait
porter la masturbation assez normal les
hommes qui sont les hommes qui se
masturbe c'est normal je dois te
direction nocturne des orgas nocturne
c'est celle là c'est comme symbole
manquiez lotis mais nous autres c'est
comme c'est aboud s'il faut pas trop
faire sur le fait ce que tu disais plus
tôt aussi que qui que bien des femmes
qui savent même pas qui c'est
militariste va-t-elle langage comme ça
ce qu'ils montrent qu'ils sont pas
parlés la magnifique ayant pas parler de
cela magnifique sans parler de logan ont
maintenant pcc se sait ce qui arrive
c'est rare qu'on en parle
nous autres c'est un peu ce qui a je
pense qu'on veut créer avec libre
expression s'est créé un save space où
les gens peuvent en parler puis
normalisées ces discussions le service
quelle joie ni decamp point g prison de
fond stevens et je pense que c'est ce
qui est apprécié par l'arrêt lors
d'histoire et parce que si c'est dire
et merci merci de mettre des mots sur ce
que ce que je vis merci d'en parler de
nous faire sentir normale tout en vient
à la question de se faire sentir normal
donc ses seuls amis sont des bri
expression c'est vraiment normaliser les
sujets entourant la sexualité à travers
différentes expériences dit on va parler
de polyamour m on va parler de mingue
fournès à travers la sexualité et on va
parler démonstration et si on va aller
chercher des sujets qui sont à bout qui
met des mots sur ces choses là parce que
c'est des choses qui existent et
tellement d'autres le quinté plus jeunes
9 comparé sexualité me semble que la
façon que je le conçois s'était passé ce
n'était pas des discussions saines parce
qu'on peut en traiter de la sexualité
comme si elle existait à l'extérieur de
notre fait mais temps on parlait dont
parlait de mes temps on parlait souvent
de sexe mais genre on en faisait
longtemps que ça ne m'était jamais pour
el tri mais je n'ai jamais vu un dôme
tout le cam et ont quand même temps on
n'était jamais
dans cette discussion le triste de tout
le temps discussion un peu
extradiégétique je peux utiliser ce
terme la question m'a pas précisément ce
que je veux exprimer
mais c'est ça c'est tout le temps comme
quelque chose qui existait à l'extérieur
nous ce n'est pas notre sexualité on n'a
jamais parlé vraiment notre sexualité
je me souviens qu'ils essaient go un an
plus vieux qui m'avait expliqué comment
masturber qui m'avait dit que c'est
super sub qui continuent à manille va se
passer de quoi tu vas sortir de quoi
kiki qui montrent l'ex parce que tu
étais venu noté je tends mouais j'ai
essayé ce qui effectivement mais je
savais pas si c'était quand même 11 12
ans tu avais tu déjà eu ce genre de
sentiment là quand il dort même temps
jamais eu de jamie d'éjaculation
d'actions non non non non puis s'est
bâtie il faut que je me réveillais genre
complètement je mérite ou non mais
mais vous savez pourquoi elle les hommes
se réveillent en érection le matin non
ça parce que sans fard ni nécessairement
non effectivement juste à l'épicerie bio
est en fait c'est que on a notre système
nerveux
il ya comme deux branches y ait ce
système le j'embarque un peu dans la
théorie le même on est système
sympathique qui les systèmes qui gens
c'est un lion qui court après tu
parcours épique c'est juste le fait que
je bouge les bras ce moment c'est mon
système pas est sympathique puis on ne
le parasympathique qui va s'occuper plus
de quota de gestion et de fer bâtons
quartier comme plus comme je les
présente plus
qu'est-ce-qui réflexes dans ton corps
qui l'érection c'est pas ton sympathique
qui va faire en sorte dans le fond le
camp tête en érection tes petits muscles
sont au repos
j'ai l'impression du contraire
l'érection c'était un réflexe du corps
puis quand tu dors ben c'est ton système
de relaxation sait-on réflexes et pas
dépendre à courir le candidat fax et on
parlera sympathique qui embarque puis on
appelle ce point tenchu août parce que
c'est un système qui fait en sorte
qu'elle entre en direction parce que tu
es en relaxation
je t'ai jeudi ce poète bandés pendant
qu'ils courent c'est une ironie non non
non c'est bien moi non mais j'aime
ouvrir une porte la pire mais tant qu
est ce qu a reçu j'imagine que c'est
juste la vibration le mais des fois
mettons goethe en championnat et relax
c'est juste la paix rédaction du soir le
hbcc barack obama ya peut-être une bosse
qu'hier frottements pleut il ya comme
quelque chose qui déclenche mais c'est
sa secte et c'est toujours tes cet état
en charente cherche son chemin que tu
étais dans le trafic pour tout le
regarde si ça se passe dans le temps le
chômage parce qu est demeuré bien percer
enfin quand tu est en érection tes
muscles sont au repos puis quand tu es
petit pont en direction le bain étaient
des petits muscles sont partis de
fonctionner pour garder ton pénis et
pour une érection que
fecan a beaucoup de sens que je suis
revenu le matin et l'annoncé juste un
état de relaxation tmx ont jusqu'à ma
passe des fois ça m'est arrivé de
commencer mettons à avoir une relation
sexuelle avec mon mon morning good way
puis de justice le père là mais pendant
la relation d'argent aux pieds nos
acquis c'est au cinquième
on comptait vraiment s'était jamais
arrivé puis après je retrouve le même
jamais eu d'élections matinale à la ddt
est pas grave de perdurer dans le temps
où je suis plus près 10 le matin hier
matin que tu sois moi mais j'ai ce soir
c'est comme le matin celle où j'ai tout
fait mais oui mais oui mais qu'est ce tu
vois ça c'est vraiment important
engagement de parenthèse sur le désir
sexuel et en aucun cas qui sait
préconçues s'exposer à être le soir
l'analyse coucher y apprendre que sa
douche bien attirer toute affaire c'est
correct mais tu mets ton justement
j'avais un homme qui me consultait parce
qu'il y avait des problèmes érectiles
j'étais comme ça quand tu es ce que vous
avez le plus beau direction les
martégaux matin quitté ce monde du goût
si je devais rire nos corps fonctionne
tout différemment fait que ses pieds
étaient là au moins il m'a retenu sous
des quarante ans le qu'ils avaient des
relations sexuelles avec sa famille est
un homme d'une soixantaine d'années qui
est ce qu'il ya des relations sexuelles
avec sa femme
ce sont les soirs mais pas 6 pollock ton
corps fonctionne le mieux
mais c'est en tout cas d'actes et si
c'est pas c'est pas ton corps de
s'adapter aux pratiques seat aux
pratiques c'est pratique on adapte en
encore ses futures envers ces thèmes et
on met ton ma partenaire ce temps si
elle aime le seul soir
je trouve cela matin et enfin compromis
entre les deux mais s'appuie dessus
si si si sa femme lui c'est un vrai
savoir matin c'est sur que c'est pas
mieux mais tu es dans le temps les
autres l'important c'était d'avoir des
rapports sexuels
bach le tu trouves le moment les
meilleurs moments et plus haute est
évidemment est pas toujours contrôlés
comme en tant qu en fonction mais tu
peux se prévoir des moments paie des
gens que ça va mais c'est pas spontanée
moins piquante avoir rencontré tonton
facebook benefit le je sais que c'est
prévu pourtant telle bonne fac et c'est
un poste où je trouve que là le sud le
seul point négatif à métis au calendrier
m'étonne c'est que si tu arrives au
moment fatidique qui s'attendent pas vu
que c'était prévu comme une pression sur
m
oui ça revient beaucoup mais c'est le
moment que la sexualité est pas juste la
pénétration et leur guise en gamme et
fax attentes pour qu'est-ce qui tente
thomas maillet plane fil 70 caltech toth
que tu peux passer avec dans ta
partenaire qu'est ce qu'il tente
patrick est la patrie va t'amener sictom
a pu cesser tout l'été chaque écoute on
est mi temps doit encore beaucoup mais
on se connaît depuis
oui ben toi comment tu as découvert que
commence à marcher
la masturbation dans ma douche
au début je pensais qu'il est et il y
avait on avait un gel douche qui pouvait
faire soit des petits jets autour des
gros jets au centre manny était brisée
il fait que joe tour puis un gros jeu au
sens pour ma gueule j'ai passé mon gland
quelquefois en dessous de ce que j'ai
fait dans au nom taberna pilat
plus je veux laisser la plage et camions
en vie si je pensais que c'était un an
l'ipc
mais ce n'est pas une envie de pisser
que j'ai fait hacké mon cas je fais ça
c'est que c'est cool puis puis c'est
l'autre je découvre qu'ils partageaient
tue moi et puis deux puis j'avais une
érection suite à ça plus je voyais que
ça continue de lutter je veux dire
j'avais déjà vu quelqu'un faire ce
mouvement les gens votent cros et au
crosstour est l'espèce de d'envoyer
chier quelqu'un qu'on faisait le nom de
clash avec six avaient un lien avec mon
pénis faite le j'ai fait de la prison
j'ai beaucoup saigné beaucoup de la
passation du savoir mais c'est existe
pas de problème c'est que ça va se passe
de façon mais dont là on veut passer du
nouveau savoir si j'allais au stade
parce que là on est fiers de discussion
là sur un podcast va est écouté par des
dizaines de milliers de personnes puis
on veut passer un savoir qui est un
petit peu plus savoir du meilleur savoir
passer du meilleur savons suivant je
pense
merci infiniment merci à vous parce
qu'on voit ce qu'on ne suis content et
côtoie ce que si le temps est julian
clients veulent plus sur instagram au
lit avec anne marie
j'ai aussi deux secteurs que j'ai
commencé récemment aux liens avec un
mari aussi donc les 3 60 exactement
sinon libre expression d'animapp toutes
les semaines et on va recommencer
bientôt y est les épisodes nous avions
battu en main
ouais exactement donc on est autant
remettre en place on a là bas j'ai sa
gamme libre expression le pour les
prochains détails parfois mettons aussi
les gens qui écoutent soupe qui
s'escrime jamais une telle somme
oscillant parler avec quelqu'un
rencontré quelqu'un mais ils peuvent
décrire en fait ils peuvent venir
consulter
mais sinon c'est comme question mais
j'imagine qu'ils seraient sans le besoin
ce qu'il pense que peut-être que c'est
nécessaire c'est assez pour dire au
revoir
c'était du questionnement pis
oui pis et les professionnels de la
santé sont le sexologue professionnelle
en sexologie et été ratée on est
vraiment là pour ça et c'est que ce soit
des questionnements des gens nés des
folles qui des idées cliente qui vient
de voir qu'ils sont comme je sais pas
vraiment pourquoi je veux consulter mes
chantiers quelque chose puis on finit
toujours par effectivement travailler
sur quelque chose qui si tu veux
t'épanouir sexuellement c'était des
questionnements des dysfonctions des
problèmes dans les relations chez terra
les professionnels sont là pour ceux qui
hésitent peut on est vraiment là pour ça
la liste de motifs de raisons consulter
ils ont vraiment écoute toute influence
notre sexualité fac est que ce soit des
questionnements pour ton identité ton
orientation que ce soit pour trop de
désir sexuel pour asi de désir sexuel
les corps des désirs sexuels dans ton
couple que ce soit parce que tu es des
douleurs lors des rapports sexuels qui
étaient des troubles érectiles des
troupes de l'orgasme garde
il y en a tellement dit raison que ce
soit parce que tu dis que de la violence
conjugale que ce soit parce que même
heat il n'y en a point c'est tout ça que
tu as besoin de consulter à ces égards
le il est plus petit peut nous poser les
questions là on va te dire un outil
moment je joue et je vois jamais prendre
quelqu'un si j'ai pas les compétences de
le faire je vous référer aux
professionnels la sexualité c'est trop
great pour en profiter pour ça merci
beaucoup c'est vraiment